all right looks like we're now live I'm
going to give it a few moments for
viewers to pop in this is the first of
the philosophy pop ups that we're going
to be doing in yeah in April I was gonna
say March and I knew that wasn't right
so let me get everything set up here get
into the live control room so I can
actually read people's comments and
stuff and oh we've already got 12 people
here so that's that's that's pretty good
people are popping in showing up here we
go live control room okay I already have
a few cats I'm gonna take this one
Muhammad said hey mist you just in time
my girlfriend got mad well personal
relationships are one of those places
where that happens quite often so
hopefully this will be of some use so
what I'm going to do is talk a bit about
philosophy and what philosophy has to
say about anger and I'm mostly going to
talk about ancient philosophy because
the schools in antiquity we're really
quite worried about this this phenomenon
of anger and then I'll answer comments
questions all those sorts of things
people are already asking questions that
are probably going to get answered in
the presentation that I'm about to give
but we'll pick up some of the other ones
as they come in
before that I do want to point out I'm
trying something new on this in the
cards I put a poll which is something I
haven't tried in the past so if you're
interested you can take it I was just
kind of curious about how people view
their own dealing with anger
understanding anger that that sort of
thing so it's kind of a fun thing to do
and I also put in the cards which you
can find by clicking on the on the top
right corner the playlist the philosophy
playlist philosophy and anger which
contains most of my videos where I'm
discussing different philosophers and
what they have to say about anger I
don't know that I've actually put the
new Cicero's stuff in there so so I need
to get on the stink about that as well
so let me talk about ancient philosophy
and anger and yes I will in fact start
with Plato because that's one of the
first not quite systematic treatments
but but certainly discussing it in in
detail that that we can we can find I
mean there's a lot of discussions about
anger coming up in like you know Homeric
texts the Iliad and the Odyssey there's
a lot of stuff going on as well in Greek
you know tragedy some in comedy as well
and then the lyric poetry is great but
but Plato is the first person to look at
it philosophically I'd say I mean you
might say well Heraclitus has that quote
about anger is hard to master yeah but
Heraclitus is not systemic we don't
possess his book on nature where he
might have talked about it a bit more we
just have a few fragments so yeah let's
talk about Plato Plato is going to
discuss anger in terms of what he calls
the most and I'll actually write the
word down here in the chat on the side
for you and thumos is a greek term that
in some respects means like this part of
you right and it's the the riled up
portion of you sometimes it's translated
as spiritual passion there really isn't
a a great way to translate it but Plato
says in the Republic that this is the
part of us that gets angry this is that
middle part you know when we talk about
the Platonic tripartite theory of the
soul or personality you know you've got
reason on the top the rational part the
appetites down below and then you get
this middle part through most which is
the part of us that's concerned with
with sense of right and wrong and honor
and you know social status and who did
what to whom and who deserves what and
it's the part of us that that gets angry
and it's also the part of us that is
concerned with the virtue of courage or
with this counter you know vice of
cowardice and Plato seems to think that
some people are more naturally through
monic than others that means that
they're more driven by that middle range
of of desires and pleasures and
preoccupations ideally reason the
rational part should be running the show
and telling through most what to do with
them through most kind of enforces it on
the rest of the soul but quite often in
most people their soul is out of whack
and so you know there's a lot of really
interesting discussions in Plato about
what it is it gets us angry and how we
end up you know acting when we're angry
and you know I think one of the things
that's most interesting is a
contribution that Plato makes and I've
talked about this in many other places
is Plato realizes that some of the anger
that we feel comes from disagreeing with
other people and not just disagreeing
about minor things things that could
easily be resolved like it says people
don't get into you know angry shouting
matches with each other over mathematics
if you think somebody's got something
wrong show them the proof right so what
is it that we actually do get worked up
about and Plato talks about this in the
gorgeous he talks about this in the
Euthyphro it's coming up again as well I
don't exactly remember where in the
Republic the what we can call moral
values good and bad just and unjust the
beautiful and the ugly or the fine and
the the the base if you like the noble
and the ignoble these are the things
that we disagree about and not only do
we disagree about them
he even Socrates gets Euthyphro to say
that the gods disagree about these and
get angry with each
over those and these are the things that
were often mistaken about and these are
the things that often get involved in
all sorts of other issues right so we
think that we're having a discussion
about how to sort the groceries and put
them away in the cupboard but it's
really about right and wrong or
beautiful and ugly or or other things
and and then once we get into a
meta-level
and we start you know disagreeing with
each other about who is being
unreasonable or who is arguing then
there's even more possibility for that
Plato does not offer us an awful lot of
guidance when it comes to what we can do
about our anger but what he does say in
broad strokes is that we need to temper
that middle part of the soul especially
those of us in whom that's particularly
developed or acute or however you want
to put it right that that those of us
who struggle with it like in myself
interestingly you know his proposals for
how to do this have to do primarily not
with intellectual things as such so it's
not like go to go read a book on anger
management or something like that
instead what he's going to tell us is
that we need music which which works
upon the soul in different ways this is
discussed in republic book two and three
and we also need what they with the
greeks called give NOS DK exercise and
there's probably something to that so
I'm gonna leave Plato off for the time
being all right and now we'll jump into
the Aristotelian tradition Aristotle has
a lot to say about anger he doesn't have
a treatise on anger but his treatment of
anger is really the first systematic
attempt to understand it and it's it's
at a couple different levels he talks
about it at the biological level which
he doesn't really go that much into and
and I don't think is that very helpful
for us because we no longer think about
you know for humor is an anger as as
blood boiling around the heart or any
anything like that but then he talks
about it at a psychological
in great depth and detail and not just
in one work he talks about it in the
rhetoric he talks about it the two
ethics he talks about it to some degree
in the politics in the on the soul you
know there's a lot of different also in
the topics there's a lot of places where
he he goes into what's going on with us
psychologically when we get angry at how
does anger work and what does it try to
do and how can you provoke it and how
can you calm it and then there's what we
can call a moral level a third higher
level where we're evaluating anger in
terms of both you know anger in
situations and anger as a disposition
which could be excessive or it could be
you know defective Aristotle does think
that the the virtue of proud tastes
which are also right down here which we
translate sometimes as calmness or good
temper gentleness interestingly in New
Testament Greek and in the Septuagint
it's translated as meek and it's used
not only of the meek like in the Gospels
but also just to describe Moses who I
don't think if you think about the the
narratives concerning him you would not
actually consider him to be meek but he
he is a person who gets angry you know
in sort of an Aristotelian way at the
right time for the right reasons you
know to the right amount now somebody
will point out of course that he didn't
enter the the Holy Land because he got
too angry at the the you know Israelites
at a certain point and that's true right
not claiming that he's a paragon of
Aristotelian virtue but it does
illustrate the meaning of this term and
so Aristotle actually gives us a lot of
very useful insights into how we can
understand our own anger and the anger
of other people and how we could
evaluate whether we're getting angry to
the right amount you know with the right
people he doesn't give us exercises in
the way that the Stoics will but the
Aristotelian tradition
is a very important one when it comes to
understanding anger and and
unfortunately we we've lost some of the
texts within that tradition we do have
some interesting discussions by later
Aristotelians like his student and
friend and successor teo frost us about
about that as well so that you know
that's a good introduction to the
Aristotelian part then let's talk about
the Stoics so when we get to the Stoics
unfortunately we don't have a lot of
what they wrote left and i'm sure that
you know i mean there are entire
treatises on the emotions i think we
would have a lot more material to work
with if we if we did possess more of the
stoic text but even what we do have with
seneca marcus aurelius epictetus you
know eros didymus is epitome of stoic
ethics the discussions in Cicero the
discussions in dodges Laertes the bits
of MU Sonia's Rufus that we have and the
little bits of here Klee is that we have
we can put them together into a great
composit picture and we see that the
Stoics did think that that anger was
always something bad so they're they're
different than Plato or Aristotle and
Plato and Aristotle didn't think anger
was always good they thought a lot of
the time it could be quite bad but the
Stoics thought it was always bad because
it was an emotion that didn't really
serve any any useful purpose that reason
couldn't deal with and it's very
disturbing so what's really good about
the Stoics and why I use them so much in
my own writing on this and my my
practice and my work with clients is you
can see my dog one back there she's been
whining up on she was up on the bed and
now she's wandering around anyway back
to them so my own practice why do i why
do I find the the Stoics so interesting
they have some really good techniques
some strategies that you can use so I'm
gonna give you just a little glimpse of
them one
is what is in very fancy terms and I'll
write this down for you as well called
the prey medic Patsy Oh mal lorem others
will be familiar to some of you if most
misspelled paramedic paths you know they
might be terrible if I'm teaching it and
getting it wrong basically what this
means is thinking about potentially bad
things things that you think are bad
before they happen and so if you know
that you're going to be going into a
meeting and dealing with people who are
you know always a pain in the ass to you
you can think to yourself why do I allow
myself to get so upset about this what's
it going to be like going in there and
it helps to prime you for that because
you also think about what what resources
you might have to deal with the this
situation and I've used this with with
clients from you know people who are
chronically enraged all the way up to
like people at the the executive level
who just need to get an edge and not not
lose it during during meetings and to be
able to express themselves well and so
this is a very adaptable exercise
another thing and I'm gonna be a little
facetious here we'll call it you poor
bastard and it comes from Epictetus and
Epictetus has a whole chapter discussing
anger where he says why are you getting
angry at people you know why why do you
dislike people so much you know you call
this person a thief and this person this
and this person this and you get all
riled up with them don't you understand
that they're doing what they're doing
because that seems good or reasonable to
them now they're screwed up you know
Epictetus isn't saying well because they
think it's it's good for them you know
it therefore is good he's not a
relativist he's saying that's exactly
why you shouldn't be like them you know
they're screwed up is it going to help
you to be screwed up in return you know
if you think that's a successful
now what he actually says is listen you
can realize that what they're doing that
makes you angry is because they think
that's reasonable for them to do that's
a sign of how things are for them you
don't have to become angry you can
instead say to yourself don't say to the
person of course oh you poor bastard you
know you think that it's smart to
believe me and then when you do that you
find part of what stoicism provides and
actually part of what any intentional
way of approaching things provides is a
certain sort of disengagement that
allows you then to get an insight about
what's going on within your own psyche
your own personality your relations the
narratives that you're you're telling
and then you can make choices oh I want
to go this way instead of this way let
me tell you about one other well
actually I'll tell you about two other
traditions so the Epicureans you know
they also had some interesting
discussions of anger there's some
already some and Epicurus it's very
unfortunate that we've lost almost
everything that Epicurus wrote as well
because wouldn't we love to be able to
read it but we do have a few other
things you know Lucretius talks about
anger in on the nature of things and
then we do have this guy fellow Dimas
and Phil Adiemus unfortunately this the
scroll on anger was damaged when they
first started trying to unroll it and we
don't have the hope the entire thing
well what we do have is really
interesting see the Stoics would oppose
the Aristotelian 's and say ah you know
the Aristotelian they've got a totally
wrong when it comes to anger the
epicurean said both of you guys do you
Stoics you're at one extreme you were
risk the Chileans are at another we
Epicureans were right in the middle and
we're you know looking at it the way
that you framed it was in terms of
natural anger and then you know what we
could call vain or empty or
wrongheaded or however you want to
translate it anger and so you know the
Epicureans thought there was a natural
reaction and we do have to get angry
with some people some of the time to to
you might say protect ourselves but much
of what we get angry about comes from
empty opinions Kino Kino dosia and so if
we can manage to disengage ourselves
from a lot of the things that do in fact
get us riled up because we're too
invested in them we're not going to get
angry all that often and we'll get angry
when we need to be I'll mention too that
in early Christian thought anger was a
particularly troubling emotion and you
know no big surprise they're struggling
with the same issues as a community that
everybody else is but it gets a little
bit more complicated because the ones
who are doing you know high-level
Christian theology or doing Christian
philosophy you know like locked on CS
and Justin Martyr and clement of
alexandria and we can go on and on and
on these are guys who actually studied
ancient philosophy they know what the
aristotelian have to say they know what
the Epicureans have to say they know
what Plato says they know what Plutarch
says they know all these different
things and they're also trying to make
sense of it in light of Scripture and in
Scripture you get a couple different
things coming up
one is the Sermon on the Mount right
where there is this three-part
discussion of anger and it comes up in
the context of reinterpretation of the
law where where Christ says to these
crowds I haven't come to change the law
you know
I'm actually giving you something that's
a little bit tougher here again
paraphrasing right because like there's
like all Chiara 44 asks what chapter the
discourse is depicted epic to to say you
poor bastards I told you as I was
talking about it he doesn't say that I'm
paraphrasing right so paraphrasing very
roughly Christ says you know the law
says you know don't commit adultery if
you look at if you look at a woman with
lust in your heart then you're
committing adultery then he switches
immediately to talking about killing law
says don't kill don't commit murder but
I tell you and then there's this
discussion about anger if you have if
you're angry with your brother if you
call him a fool you know and so there's
a question about okay does that mean
that anger is like totally off limits
and interestingly a gloss got into there
and in some of the manuscripts it
actually says if you become if you get
angry with your brother without reason
and then others just say if you become
angry with your brother and so Christian
writers are going back and forth about
this and you will see Christian writers
criticizing each other on this John Kay
and I'll bring up those people who say
wow they inserted that gloss at John
Cassian is at one extreme anger is
always bad the only anger that's ever
good for you is getting angry at
yourself over your own vices Augustine
says well you know sometimes anger can
actually be quite useful we got to
really watch it because it has a
tendency to morph into hatred if we're
not careful and you know John Chrysostom
talks about it
there's actually a really interesting
piece by a guy called locked on seus and
locked on seus is writing officially
about the anger of God right because how
do you make sense out of that if God
gets angry what what the hell does that
mean right but he spends a lot of time
talking about human anger and he
directly compares his position to that
of the aristotelian the Epicureans and
the Stoics it's a it's a piece that I've
long wanted to do some some work on and
if I ever do have the time I want to
write quite a bit about about locked
honest and and anger and that that whole
idea that he's working with so very
interesting stuff and they had you know
they engage in a lot of throughout this
entire tradition there's all these
different images of what the angry
person is like and how the angry person
might be able to get a handle
on what's going on within their their
head so that they can you know get the
anger under control or channel it in the
right way or over time you know changing
one's habits become a less angry person
I'll tell you two before I start
answering questions why am I so
interested in this because I'm an angry
person just like an alcoholic who will
always be an alcoholic even though I've
improved in how I handle my my angry
disposition I still struggle with it
quite a bit and it's caused a lot of
problems for me in the course of my life
and not just problems for me bother
people would have to deal with me right
and so I became interested in it while I
was still in graduate school and it was
kind of a piecemeal thing and I can see
what was going on in Aristotle I also
found the Stoics useful I was interested
in what was going on with you know these
Christian writers and I was trying to
apply some of it to my own life and I
was also trying to get a sort of
theoretical handle on what did what is
going on here and at the same time I was
also like using resources that I was
finding in contemporary psychology and
it was really surprising to me how how
much of that was either not as good or
was just sort of repeating with a little
bit of additional stuff what the
ancients had already had to teach us so
it was you know that that became sort of
fascination with me and so really Mike
my research into anger has been going
back oh close to 20 years I probably
should have written my dissertation
about it you know but but I didn't I
wrote on other stuff and and eventually
you know I've written a few things here
and there but eventually I do need to
get get these books done so all right
now I'm gonna start taking questions I'm
gonna start with this one here from Rob
Rob Roberts thanks so much for your
videos love Kierkegaard
yeah Kierkegaard is an interesting guy
you know he he has a lot to say about
the emotions
in particular alright so let me jump up
to this Francis is there a difference
between intellectual anger and purely
emotional anger I don't know what
intellectual anger would be as opposed
to emotional anger and here's an
interesting thing that the ancients
pointed out there is no such thing as
purely emotional anger anger already as
a human emotion as opposed to just a
merely animal response involves all
sorts of higher-level cognition that's
part of why Plato I think wanted to say
that it's not just an appetite like
wanting to get laid
or you know stuff your faithful food or
get drunk or something like that he said
it's it's in this middle part of the
soul because it involves conceptions of
justice and injustice it oftentimes
engages in planning and all sorts of
other things along these lines I hear
the dog whining downstairs come up Amica
come on she wants to get up the stairs
but she's old and it takes her a while
to do so so we'll see if she just winds
down there and how long she does it or
if she actually you know Spurs herself
into action do you desire something
strongly enough good example animals you
know they will eventually do things but
yeah there's so anger is this is why
anger is so dangerous you know it
hijacks or seduces our our higher
faculties it brings them in and uses
them and often time then blinds us to
what's going on Aristotle says anger is
like a hasty servant who listens to half
of the instructions and then no rushes
off to do them so anger sees that there
is some sort of thing that could be
perceived as an insult or slight and it
carries out a reasoning process he
actually uses the word Sulu logos aim to
cyllage eyes it's illage eise's that it
ought that we ought to go take revenge
on that person so yeah pardhu I'm an
Indian student going through books of
ein Rand intended to learn philosophy so
please tell me the way to learn
philosophy recommended
well don't start with rant because Rand
is going to steer you wrong about nearly
all of the history of philosophy I don't
think that she is not worth reading but
there's so many other people who are
better to read and also you know when it
comes to like studying the history of
philosophy there's a lot of kind of
tendentious histories of philosophy out
there so you want to find somebody who's
reliable cobblestone is good
middle-of-the-road kind of stuff I may
actually write that for those of you
that are interested I mean that's sort
of the standard when I was in grad
school free to cobblestone don't use
Russell's history of philosophy
I mean Russell's interesting and I
actually do work on him because he's an
interesting guy in his own right but
again bad historian of philosophy don't
use Hegel's history of philosophy either
unless you're really interested in Hegel
because you're only going to get his
take on it
so where do you begin start reading
Plato I mean start a and don't feel like
oh I'm gonna go back to the
pre-socratics first now just start
reading Plato and then read some
Aristotle then read some Stoics start
going through it in sequence I would say
I mean that's not the only way you can
do philosophy but that's the advice that
I pretty consistently give people so it
actually has something very nice here
hope you and your wife are feeling
better thanks
yeah I mean we've been struggling with
this this flu that it on average has you
know lingered with most people for about
six weeks and I kind of poo pood that
idea at first and then realized after a
while of losing you know time because of
like you know working really hard and
then being totally exhausted that I
needed to take it a bit more carefully
and that I needed to believe that this
flu thing was for real you know plus I'm
47 years old so I can't bounce back as
quickly from from illnesses but I am
feeling better I still am not fully up
to snuff but I did manage to get four
workouts in this week rather proud of
that
and I did manage to shoot about you know
seven or eight videos this week that's
always exhausting for me I'll probably
feel a bit exhausted after this because
it's kind of a high intensity thing and
I have another meeting later on today so
alright Socrates Plato says I saw on
your bookshelf that you had some
bataille what do you think of him
you know but ties an interesting guy I
generally have not enjoyed interacting
with but tie scholars but I find Batali
interesting just not interesting enough
to to spend an awful lot of time with
let's see what else we got here
zu honden height I'm sure you're being
tired of asked about to lose often but I
wonder if you had any thoughts about his
connections and influence concerning
stoicism well he has no influence
whatsoever when it comes to stoicism
you're asking about the influence of
stoicism on Toulouse I imagine right I
mean so here's the thing this is one of
the things one of my professors pointed
out to me when I was like bringing
Toulouse into all these modern
philosophy classes they had this great
book on live nets and Spinoza and all
that I actually presented it losses
Nietzsche book to our graduate students
you're always getting more to lose than
you are the the thinker he's writing
about so you know he is bringing up the
Stoics but he's doing very very
different stuff than then the Stoics
were doing I mean you know think about
the conception of nature and the role
that it plays in stoicism and think
about you know to lose his concept of
the rhizome and and all of that they
just don't fit in with each other so you
think about Deleuze is more like taking
other philosophers it's kind of like
launching pads for his own projects I
would say Francis s do you think there's
techniques of emotional mastery you need
to self-help that can aid people in
developing and actualizing more
preferable emotions without the aid of
philosophy alone I got to think about
how okay so
our other techniques of emotional
mastery unique to self-help no self-help
is kind of a melange of you know things
from psychology philosophy theology this
and that self-help is just you know and
self up ranges from the crappiest crap
all the way up to some really great
stuff but it's just really just a
catch-all category now that can aid
people in developing and analyzing more
preferable emotions yeah sure but
without the aid of philosophy alone I
don't even know what that means if that
means not just relying on philosophy
well if you're just relying on
philosophy you're doing bad philosophy
because the Aristotelian tradition you
know you you roulette you check out
everybody else's stuff plato's
constantly drawing out other people's
stuff you know Stoics you know to do
philosophy is not just to sort of
retreat into your own little domain
although academic philosophy is often
like that you know if Aristotle were
around today if Thomas Aquinas were
around today the Stoics were around
today they would in fact be engaging
with modern psychology what sociology
has to tell us you know now they
wouldn't be doing it an uncritical way
they wouldn't be for example you know
swallowing entire things from
evolutionary psychology or you know
emergent fields like that without you
know looking at those things very
critically but yeah I mean I think it's
best to take kind of an approach that
draws on what we've got in philosophy
that's particularly good and then also
draws on other other resources that we
have you know I think that's that's
important all right let me take one from
Pygmalion when it comes to learning a
new language like German to read
philosophy should I just gain the
vocabulary by jumping into the text
immediately or should I look for other
resources well I mean if you haven't
actually got German down first you need
to learn the grammar and the vocabulary
and so that's going to take you it
should take you like a
if it's a year a very intensive year
probably a couple years then you can
start reading literature and philosophy
can be part of that literature but even
you know when you're reading you know
stuff in for reading it for philosophy
you do want to also like learn the
literature because the people that
you're writing are the people you're
reading are also in reading that that
same literature so you know like if
you're going to learn French to read the
card I mean you actually need to learn
Latin because you wrote more and Latin
than in French but let's say you're
gonna learn French to read Descartes you
would also want to read the other people
writing in French at the time to get
something get an idea of the context
right
so yeah and I will point out too if you
want to learn the old German script then
you want to get yourself an old like
teach yourself German like the one that
I used and it's very useful to be able
to read the old German script the front
door because so so few other people can
read it so it puts you in a kind of a
different class all right let's scroll
back up and see what we got here Karl
writes the example about going into a
meeting where people make you furious is
way too relatable from here yeah I think
you're not you're not unique in that the
meetings are terrible quite often brandy
writes the best revenge is to not be
like that
that's the playing off the epictetus
thing you know it's still considering it
to be revenge it's still kind of
reactive
namsom what does epic to you to say
about jealousy is related to anger not
much he doesn't talk about and we want
to also distinguish Envy everything
about envy or jealousy because those are
two different things jealousy is when
you want to keep other people's hands
off of your stuff like you know you're
jealous of your spouse you're jealous of
your position Envy is when you want what
somebody else has he does talk about
Envy and he says that it's always going
to cause you problems he doesn't
associate it immediately with anger
but what he does connect it with is in a
chapter on contentiousness on the
contentious and the brutal contentious
is people who are driven into conflict
and he says look if you want what other
people have and they want what you have
you're going to be in conflict or if you
both want the same thing if you want if
you're too obsessed with externals like
if you're all fighting for who's gonna
dominate the conversation or who's gonna
have the corner office or you know whose
lawn is the best or something like that
you're gonna you're gonna get in
arguments with them you're gonna fight
with them he says you know in a case
like that
a father is hoping for his her son is
hoping for his father to die so he can
get the farm you know Rocco any mention
about anger related to relationship so
yeah I mean if we're talking about the
ancients they they do talk about people
getting angry in relationships Aristotle
has a very funny example where he's
talking about this this guy he's talking
about in terms of justice and injustice
this guy who's from an anger prone
family and you know the the sons abused
the fathers and the son says it's okay
for me to drag my father by the hair to
the threshold because that's how far he
dragged his father well here's the
structure of a relationship I think
you're something that I've been devoting
a lot of thought to and I've been using
with clients when we think about virtue
ethics we often think in terms of
changing habits and so we pay attention
to our habits so people do journaling
right for example and they're like okay
how many times I lose my temper today
and they set up if they're doing
psychiatric stuff we set up a treatment
plan and you know how can we make this
measurable and all that that's important
habit is is really central equally
central and interpenetrating with habits
are two other dimensions one of them is
relationships if you wind up having the
same fights with different people in
different contexts you're probably the
the
the the thing that's holding it all
together so you want to look at the kind
of relationships that you're choosing or
finding yourself in the other thing is
narrative the stories that we tell
ourselves about who we are who other
people are the way the world works all
of those kind of fuse in together so I
think those are important
bourgeois you have you helped me with
anger you helped me with my anger with
your videos thank you I'm glad to hear
that it's it's always a surprise to me
that videos can be helpful because
they're not helpful for me when I watch
other people's videos but if they if
they help you I'm glad to hear that
there's a good one from j2b to Nick is
there any noticeable difference between
home and quite as for his anger compared
to air assault so it's a great question
so Aquinas is taking Aristotle John of
Damascus
you know Augustine a bunch of other
thinkers and bringing them all together
in a synthesis Aquinas is he's got a
different anthropology than Aristotle
does as a matter of fact he manages I
think in some respects to get
Aristotle's psychology wrong and he when
he calls the will the Volant ask Thomas
Aquinas really is closer to what
Aristotle is calling Pro a racist it's
not what what Aristotle calls blase as
which then gets translated as rational
appetite but that's oh that's a very
obscure point right Aquinas does have a
really great discussion about anger and
and I draw upon some of his insights one
of the advances that I think Aquinas
makes is identifying that anger is
really fundamentally about what we call
difficult goods that is goods that in
order to achieve we have to face some
sort of difficulty we have to endure
problems we have to struggle against
resistance anger is concerned with that
that part of us this is in some ways
connects it more closely to to
[Music]
Plato I mean take a pause Amica come on
come on come up here don't wind down
there come on up as the dogs get older
they get goofier and goofier and goofier
alright let me go with this an ordered
whole most people struggle with emotions
because of how it affects other people
do you think philosophers also frame it
as how emotions affect reason as if it
is another person well it's an
interesting question I mean yeah I think
the reason why most people wind up
seeking treatment for their or you know
therapy or working on their emotions is
not usually just because of how it feels
for them and I think with anxiety it's
same people who have anxiety often do
seek things out for their own sake
people who are depressed people who are
angry it's often other people saying wow
you've got to go and see somebody you
got to talk with somebody
do you philosophers frame it as how
emotions affect reason as if it's
another person I've never seen that
although Aristotle does have a really
interesting discussion about the parts
of the soul and justice where he's like
well you know you can be just to
yourself because you're kind of like a
community of parts so yeah there's
something kind of like that but yeah
alright so there's two things here about
Buddhist you have any favourite Buddhist
thinkers and then principled uncertainty
Buddhists are scared of life that's not
a nice thing say I know who I know
principled uncertainty is somebody that
we've talked quite a bit but so I think
he's probably joking there but do I have
any favourite Buddhist thinkers no
because I don't read a lot of
contemporary Buddhist stuff you know I
and that's that's mainly just from being
too busy on my part you know I've read
Buddhist scriptures and they're
interesting stuff but I wouldn't
have anything that's that's favorites
chases any general thoughts on political
anger or dealing with political anger
well that's a good one so you know
Aristotle has a lot to say about that
I think the Stoics Plutarch says where
I'll have useful things to say about
that the same general dynamics that
affect individuals that make them angry
can apply to groups and quite often we
get what what the ancients called stasis
I'm gonna write that down for you too
and stasis can be easily translated it's
faction but you can think of it as a
social breakdown it's a fundamental
political theory problem you know
something like Hobbes is very interested
in - and yeah anger plays an incredibly
important role in that anger can be used
to motivate people I mean we've seen
this right with Facebook posts that that
get people riled up
they are easiest to go viral
and many of them can be political and
you know one of the dangers with anger
is anger tends to make the people who
are feeling it see things with a kind of
tunnel vision not really take account of
the consequences of what they're saying
or doing
they're often unfair to the people that
they're angry with and then it often
spills over and other people I I've had
so many Facebook conversations where I
just give up on the conversation because
somebody who's worked up about something
takes me to be saying something that I'm
not saying just because I'm pointing out
that that they're not totally right
about something you know I'm on the
other side anger does tend to do that
and I think in in recent times anger has
become a noxious force on on both sides
of the political spectrum here in the
United States and it's you know it's a
serious issue now learning how to deal
with it or perhaps even say surf on the
wave of anger and if philosophers have
anything you
let's say about that I think they they
do here's a good question Rocco do you
think anger is closely related to our
need to control external reality then
respond with it when we fail yeah quite
often and this is something where I
think the Stoics are really helpful for
us and that notion of the the Academy of
control right anger tends to be about
things that we don't really have control
over like other people's thoughts and
views on us and interestingly anger it's
not just that it in terms of response
but also in terms of what anger then
leads us to do anger makes us feel as if
we can control things more than we can
this is why people like to be angry
rather than being afraid or hurt or sad
or anxious or you can pick all sorts of
other or embarrassed right it's easier
to feel angry because I need to get you
know worked up right yeah often times
the angry person does attempt to assert
control and they don't have control over
themselves you want to get somebody
angrier tell them hey man you're out of
control you know get control over
yourself then they get even angrier
alright
retro gamer says cheers thanks that's
very nice of you all right let me go up
a bit now so raba rabbets says political
anger is a leveling it can be leveling
is a term that Kierkegaard uses is
similar to what nature calls results a
month and sometimes they can be
connected together sometimes they're not
you know Martin Luther King actually had
some interesting things to say about
anger you can find in a blog post on my
blog or exes do you know a TK about
righteous anger in political life let's
see here
principal don't certainly anger well
used well can facilitate justice yeah
they can and I think that's why Plato so
early on was interested in figuring how
do we harness it
now again this is where like the plate
'no sand the aristotelian czar in one
side the Stoics are an another seneca
says listen anything that you can do
with anger motivating you you can do
with practical reason motivating you as
well and then you won't go you know it
off off the the right path and doing so
Hail Mary ass is it wrong to simply
start with the core books we're back to
like what should I do in philosophy when
I did my undergrad starting with the
Greeks and a might meant thought was the
best you can start with whatever you
want right it's it's your life it's your
your studies you know one of the things
too is you're gonna go back and rework
things so if you want to start with the
Greeks and then jump over the medieval
's and go straight to you know for the
skip the early modern and go straight
into the Enlightenment sure you can do
that but then you know you probably do
want to go back some time and read
Boethius and and you know read
lactantius and read Augustine and Thomas
Aquinas and Anselm and all these other
people that you're missing alright
Chino ashtray can you please talk about
philosophical therapy as a profession
well that's an interesting thing yeah so
I guess there's a couple things to say
one is this was part of what philosophy
was doing early on you know you can look
at what what Plato is attempting to do
and what Socrates was attempting to do
is a kind of therapy right Aristotle
himself is not doing that although his
works can certainly be used for that the
Stoics were clearly doing that the
Epicureans clearly doing that even the
skeptics and the early Christian writers
are doing that as well so this concept
of therapy up it's going on for a long
time and another way we talk about this
is philosophy is a way of life right and
that continues really all the way on
into the early modern period I was just
you know looking at the cart
you see them on the chalkboard there cuz
I'm shooting some videos on the
discourse the Cardoz philosophy is a way
of life it's not just abstract stuff
he's trying to rework things for a way
in which one could live a rational
coherent life right and and that
continues on until philosophy becomes
overly you know specialized and academic
now what about the present right part of
what I do so my official title is
philosophical counselor because I am an
Appa that's American Philosophical
practitioners Association certified
philosophical counselor but you know I'm
equally happy calling it philosophical
coaching philosophical practice
I don't usually call it philosophical
therapy because of the Association of
therapy here with something medical but
I could just as well call it that and so
what I do is I work with clients and a
good bit of what I do is what a you know
a counselor or spiritual director would
be doing is listening and responding but
I bring to bear resources coming out of
philosophy and I do this with clients
who are just individual people
struggling with things I do this in
terms of executive coaching and there's
other others out there like me doing
that and you know there's entire
societies you know here in the United
States and Canada and Europe and other
places and so it's kind of a it's a cool
profession I I really enjoy it I was
doing it before I actually got certified
and that's why I got certified because
people were coming to me and they'd be
like yeah I've got this problem we
talked about it and I kind of myself
doing more and more of that and and
finding you know the Philosopher's who
I'm studying to be very useful resources
for others and it's great when you see
things like that click and people you
know using philosophy to work on their
life problems uncle Jam nothing wrong
with an R and really may be a better
place to start if anything Aristotle's
good though totally wrong Rand is a
terrible historian of philosophy you
want to start with her go ahead but you
know speaking as somebody who actually
teaches Rand and is one of the few
philosophers who thinks that there's
some merit to her ideas no you don't you
don't begin with her nor do you rely on
her fur for verdicts of other
philosophers and Aristotle is good
Aristotle's way better although I don't
suggest starting with Aristotle Huw why
do philosophical therapy when you can
read the fellow Kalia okay then didn't
read the fellow Kalia they'll tell you
that you probably need a spiritual
director so you're gonna do
philosophical therapy anyway so all
right I'm gonna skip down a bit Francis
what makes you not a Hegelian how do you
think the method of eminent critique is
too simple I didn't say the method is
too simple but I don't think that that's
what makes you a Hegelian you know I'm
not a Hegelian just like I'm not a
Aristotelian or a stoic I'm an eclectic
I draw on a variety of different
thinkers and approaches and I bring them
together I mean you could say well then
you're really a Hegelian because you're
doing something dialectal yeah but so is
Aristotle and suppose Thomas Aquinas so
yeah
Yasmin's I missed your proton anger can
you summarize I cannot summarize I spent
about you know probably 15 20 minutes
talking about it this is a video that'll
be available afterwards so that that's
that's really easy to access jr. do you
like Anthony Kenny's for volume history
of philosophy I think it's great with
the caveat that splitting the more
in-depth discussions and the topical
chapters isn't always the best approach
I have not looked at it for a very long
time so I don't really have much to to
say about it I can tell you one thing
that Kenny was one of the translators of
the Blackfriars edition of Aquinas his
treatise on the emotions not such a good
translation but Kenny's Kenny's an
interesting person I can tell you one
thing McIntyre who you know I've had the
opportunity to talk with
very highly so I don't know if that
means anything to you but yeah
Roberts how our emotions represented as
a phenomenological interpretation well
I'm not sure what's being asked there
you know you're asking what
phenomenologist make of of emotions
depends on the phenomenologist you know
Heidegger treats them in terms of mood
in a tune meant he's actually got some
some discussions of them and in many of
his different treatises mock Schaller
you know that whole sequence like
running through von Hildebrand all the
way up to Adrienne pepper Zak I would
say are very focused on the emotions you
know you get other phenomenologist like
Solomon writing entire books on the
emotions
Gabrielle Marcel so it's not there's no
one phenomenological treatment of the
emotions there's a whole bunch of very
interesting very insightful things mr.
Dereham paaji I often feel mental and
physically exhausted after hours and
hours of thinking it even produces a
severe amount of anxiety when I
encounter difficulties would seem
unsolvable help well then if you can
turn it off don't do our significance of
thinking Descartes actually who's you
know a brilliant thinker said that we
can only really think with the pure
intellect as opposed to using the the
imagination and mixing these things
together for maybe an hour at a time and
that maybe only once a month or so
so you know you don't have to place the
pressure upon yourself that you'd have
to resolve philosophical problems
sometimes it takes years and years to
sort your way through it
you know so I would say if you can take
that pressure off yourself that will
probably help you out hmm
there's an interesting one Corvo what
does Nietzsche mean by decadence he's
using the French term there which just
means decadence in English I can never
figure out what he means by that term
everyone and everything seems decadent
to him well not everything is decadent
but there are many things that are
decadent and decadence is simply when
you you know decline from one period to
the next
or an organism or a social group
declines in some of its you know
impulses reactions and Nietzsche thought
that much of European culture was
decadent in that way you know he thought
of you know movements towards democracy
for example as as a type of decadence
it just means you know a degeneration
and and Nietzsche was not you know
unique and using this term a lot of
other people are are using that term as
well so raba roberts do you draw any
links between Dostoevsky and
Kierkegaard's view of faith well I can't
say that I know what dos day on skis
view of faith actually is I can say that
I know what dos day on skis characters
views are and they they're all over the
map right but I mean so let's talk about
Kierkegaard Kierkegaard thinks that that
faith in at least one sense is not just
sort of like a dumb belief for people
who can't think or you know it's just a
starting point the way the that you know
people and his time we're making it the
people that were you know he's attacking
his Hegelian he calls faith sort of this
this leap right into into something that
he thinks is there but you don't know is
really there until you encounter it and
he calls faith you know a passion and
it's it's not something that you can
sort of universalize and put onto
everybody what I do like I'll say this
this won't really answer the question as
such but it may give you a little bit of
insight I like religious thinkers for
whom religion didn't make anything
simpler so I like Kierkegaard I like
Dostoevsky like Gabrielle Marcel you
know I like thinkers like that even
Thomas Aquinas
you know why does he write a wholesome
motel oh yeah among the other works
because things are complicated because
when you introduce God or or you know
the human relation to God and faith into
the picture it doesn't is you know
there's some people are like oh well God
is God's in his heaven Bibles in my
hands now everything falls into place
that's clearly not what these religious
thinkers think the GK Chesterton it
would be another great example of
somebody in that boat as well no it's it
makes the the whole world more tricky
more complicated and I think that you
could say that about Dostoevsky you know
people who are struggling people who
wrestle with God those are the religious
thinkers I'm interested in all right Jan
are there any positive uses for anger
well I mean I think there are you know
this is something where I differ from
the Stoics and I also differ from Cicero
who I like very much and I also differ
from John damask in who I like very not
John Demasi and I'm blanking out his
name the other John anyway we'll come
back to that in a moment I think that
anger can be useful on more Aristotelian
in that respect but I think we have to
be very very very careful with them I
think that if you want it to be useful
you do need to go through some sort of
tempering process you need to sort of
you know compare notes with others again
to bring up the example of Martin Luther
King one of the things that the marchers
actually did to prepare themselves for
that the crap that they were going to be
put through by my white racists when
they were marching for civil rights was
they would actually have a gauntlet that
they would walk and during this gauntlet
they would play a role play the sort of
things that would be said against you
you know and they would push you around
and if you lost your temper you didn't
get to March because you know that would
not be serving a useful purpose
all right mr. Donham [ __ ] as a
follow-up how do I stop myself from
getting anxious while reading philosophy
I often feel mentally exhausted and
anxious when I can't visualize some
concepts especially when reading Hegel
well I guess the one place to start is
to remind yourself that to begin with
Hegel thinks that if you are visualizing
the stuff that's still in the realm of
representation its conceptual thinking
but you don't need to visualize
everything again you can take the
pressure off of yourself you don't need
to understand everything understanding
is something that builds over time and
is to some degree contingent and you
know in a way it can be
counterproductive to be anxious about
getting it right or fully understanding
it that can often prevent you from you
know having the openness to the ideas to
where they suddenly start making sense
and here's another thing - you know I'll
talk about my experience with Ansem you
know Anselm's ontological argument he
never calls it ontological by the way
that's that's later on that's caught his
language in prosto Gian - and then and
three and four and the whole pro slogan
is actually the unum argumentum by the
way I'll read it and sometimes I'm like
wow yeah I finally see it it all makes
sense and then I have to explain it to
somebody and I'm like oh maybe it
doesn't make sense I think I'm missing
something here I thought it like grows
upon me and it's like hey think about
this idea I think about this idea now I
bring that one up for two reasons one is
if you read an Psalms Pro slogan and you
read the the preface he struggled with
it in the same way right the other thing
is Bertrand Russell himself at one time
went through something quite similar
with that so you don't have to place so
much pressure on yourself to like
totally get everything and understand
everything maybe maybe you need to
ration it out for yourself all right let
me go there we're at time but I'm gonna
go on a little bit longer since we have
more questions retro gamer is an anger a
manifestation of the intuition of an
injustice it's a it's a manifestation of
the
or the imagination this is Aristotle
would say and the Stoics following him
in this of injustice intuition that can
mean too many different things now one
can be wrong in perceiving that there's
an injustice there right one can be
wrong and imagining fantastic one can be
wrong in that sort of thing so quite
often people do get angry about stuff
that's not really unjust like you know
when you have to somebody does something
wrong you actually punish them or hold
them you know to the standards and then
I get all ticked off with you happens
with me with students all the time why
did you give me why didn't you give me
full points on this you know well
because you didn't hurt him you didn't
do all the work I told you to do oh
that's terrible you shouldn't do that
what are you getting angry about I
didn't commit injustice
I gave you everything you needed and you
didn't measure up you know it happens a
lot Robert were the Stoics against
self-defense in war whether they
pacifist I mean that that one's easy to
answer look at Stoics where are they
was Cato against self-defense and war
was was any any other ones
how about Marcus Aurelius no clearly not
I mean if you read through the stoic
stuff this will this will help you with
that core ball what do you think about
the way we treat the animals we eat
chickens cows pigs and so on
I think factory farming is terrible and
I think that we've we've unfortunately
made it very difficult for anybody who
wants to ethically farm animals to do so
in a way that can can you know compete
with factory farming factory farming is
terrible for the animals it's terrible
for the people who are working there
it's a it's a huge huge problem and they
are very very good at lobbying and
getting laws passed so that's that's a
big problem
Dharam paaji again what do you think
about the self hermeneutic method is
used by Carl Jung to interpret his
visions and their manifestations in
Indian mythology I don't know enough
about it to say anything you know so
there's not much I can say there let's
see we've got a lot of other questions
so I'm going to start skipping through
things let's see pip big guns
should we try not to be angry at all I'd
be nice that's really really really a
high standard if you can you know stop
being angry about stupid stuff that's
probably a very good idea Robert is
there a difference between
aggressiveness and anger yeah there's
there's all sorts of differences you
know agressivity is a broader category
that that overlaps with with anger you
can be aggressive without being angry
you know you can be a sadist who enjoys
inflicting things on people you could be
a thief who likes you know stealing
other people's things and hurting them
in that way right an order holds you
know any philosophers who are angry and
they're writing the only one I can say
is possibly in each other there's
different people who write angrily I
suppose you could say at different
points
Nietzsche doesn't really strike me as
angry so much maybe in parts I guess
live chests off you know sometimes who
else I know I'd have to think about that
you know all right
Mahalo how should we understand
Aristotle's terms proud taste in terms
of good amount of anger he did say the
Greek language does not have precise
words for these conceptions great work
he didn't say that it doesn't have it
for prowess he says the Greek language
doesn't have precise terms for some
things and he gives you new terms for
those how should we understand
tastes I mean you can here's where I'm
gonna refer you to the videos right if
you look up in the top corner there you
click there's a playlist of a whole
bunch of videos I've talked about this a
great length in a number of different
presentations it's that middle
disposition crowd the person who's
prowess is is there they get angry at
the right time for the right reason with
the right people to the right amount at
cetera etc and its guided by reason
oh here's a good this identity how do
you keep your cool while driving
especially when somebody drives way
slower than allowed or puts you in
life-or-death situation but nothing
happens what's the stoic answer this is
something actually that I'm writing a
piece about because this is something I
do get angry about I don't like the I
really hate people driving slow in the
left lane you know and so there there
are some stoic techniques that you can
use to help yourself while traveling it
is a big source of anger so pit big guns
what should we do in order to have
philosophy as a way of life what exactly
is philosophy as a way of life what it
sounds like you know you take philosophy
you try to live it out it's experiential
it's experimental you use resources you
apply them over time you see what
insights you get from them it's
something that's been part of philosophy
from the very beginning and and you know
what do we have to do in order to have
philosophy as a way of life start
studying people who looked at philosophy
as a way of life start applying it if
you're in an area where you can like you
want to try out stoicism find a stoic
fellowship you know find a meetup group
talk with other people that's I think
that's important with that alright
Maxime oh how does the hypothetical
absence of free will affect views about
anger
should he be angry at all if it was
inevitable so the hypothetical absence
of free will is saying that we didn't
know that we didn't have free will I
guess well if that's the case then you
know we could say then we shouldn't be
angry at people but
then again if you don't have any
freewill you're just as fated to be
angry aren't you so it doesn't matter
once you take freewill out of the
picture you lose it off a lot all right
I'm gonna skip down past the Jordan
Peterson stuff a lot of discussion there
are Devon we're on the spectrum do you
fall politically I'm off the spectrum
like a you know people of sometimes
misquoted me on this I'm too traditional
to be a conservative I'm too radical to
be a liberal so you know sometimes
people get that a little bit garbled
another great way of putting it is I'm
an Aristotelian I think that both the
left and the right are mostly crap
there's some things some ideas I like in
there and I will cooperate with them
when when I think that there's there's
something important at stake and I think
most people in the middle are you know
not particularly well-informed or or
have you know much to you SFIL to say
about politics I think that that you
know both sides both of our political
parties are are pretty crappy and and we
don't have any viable third party that I
could identify with myself so I don't I
don't fit into a spectrum Kenneth
Hester's difference between anger and
rage depends on what you want to call
them I mean they're different terms
right I mean maybe rage is more anger it
all depends on which theorist you're
looking at all right let me skip down a
bit
oh yeah aunty writes anger truly is
sweeter than honey that's coming from
homer and then Aristotle quotes that I
can I think you can control it and use
it but sooner or later it makes you
overshoot yeah exactly right there is a
pleasure involved in anger and Aristotle
gets at this and after a while this is
part of what can make anger addictive as
a response for us so all right
trombone es what book do they talk about
viewers said why go to philosophical
therapy we can when you can read the
feel of something I think you can
probably look through these comments
right most people the fill okay Leah
it's a set of books that compile
writings by Eastern Orthodox writers
very interesting stuff very often
philosophically informed using a sort of
mostly Neoplatonic anthropology in which
there's like the three parts of the soul
one of the best translations I've seen
actually is in the English version of
the Phil okay Leah of that thematic
third part of the soul as the
incandescent part of the soul
alright let's see what else we got here
I'm gonna take another couple minutes
Robert writes anger feels like it gives
energy and strength to our self defence
and war against evil yeah it's true
sometimes that's good sometimes it's not
sometimes we engage in self defense
against not evil but actually good like
when somebody is giving us feedback that
we don't like and and we think that
they're trying to bust our chops and
then we fight against them I mean
there's all sorts of stuff that we can
say hey-zeus rights
have you ever covered the marquis de
sade in any of your videos only in the
porn stuff no I'm just joking no I
haven't I haven't done anything on
decide I probably should I will probably
end up talking about him first down the
line if I ever do shoot some some stuff
on Lacan seminar 7 on the ethics of
psychoanalysis because he brings him up
right so that that's good
actually I did mention desaad in one
video where I was talking about de
Beauvoir z-- piece on must be burned
desaad
retro gamer will Aristotle give
paradigms of other emotions or do we
need to look to other thinkers for other
emotions and their consequences rhetoric
book - he doesn't cover all the emotions
but he he goes into them in great depth
so much so that Heidegger would later
call that one of the first hermeneutics
of emotions so yeah you want to look in
rhetoric book two on Draco Locke and you
say one practical way to influence my
wife's anger I'm a very calm person and
she's not Socrates allegedly had an
angry wife I'd like to ask him how he
dealt with his wife well you didn't deal
with this very well I seem to just put
up with it but he probably also pissed
her off a lot you know because I mean
think about it this guy he doesn't pay
any attention to his kids he doesn't pay
any attention to his household affairs
he goes around to dinner parties and
hanging out with everybody chatting I
mean I would I wouldn't I wouldn't like
to be married to Socrates there's
nothing I can say on here about because
I don't know you and I don't know your
wife about how to influence your wife's
anger so unfortunately no William Nelson
what languages do you know do you have
any tips for language learning I did a
video about that that's easily to Google
all right more Peterson stuff people are
really going on about that and the all
right mister whiffle's suicide attempts
why don't you want to talk about Jordan
Peterson I have a great length already
in many of these other times so you can
go back and you know watch through them
and you'll hear that sort of stuff so
Darth numerous what do you think about
khat Kant is you know somebody like
Hobbs or like many other thinkers who I
don't agree with but I find very very
interesting I teach routinely I think
he's worth worth studying I I do really
enjoy going through his works I like
seeing the sort of the big picture and
occasionally being surprised as I reread
his stuff
so I'm gonna be doing some more videos
about [ __ ] by the way you know more than
just the groundwork for the metaphysics
of morals I'm gonna do some other
conscient texts I'll probably do the
prolegomena
because I know people can use help on
that probably do you know some of his
essays like what is enlightenment and
perpetual peace and then I'll see what
else I want to dive into big pip guns
what sources do you use to study
philosophy for me it's all primary
sources I mean the one exception is when
I'm doing like academic writing or you
know oh here so here's a great example
one of my clients sent me this recently
Brad in Woods ethics and human action
and early stoicism so this is a
secondary text right Brandon when is a
researcher on stoicism so I'll read that
don't see what he has to say but I'm
always going to be going back to the
primary texts so let's see what else we
got here Lister whiffle's anger isn't
necessarily a bad thing a lot of people
have the mindset of seeing that is
negativity and avoid people like that do
you think using anger hate is a bad way
to be motivated I think that if it's the
main tool in your toolbox you're gonna
break a lot of stuff and if people are
avoiding somebody because they think
they're too angry that's probably a sign
that they are too angry you know that
said it often does get used in Canada
rhetorical way oh you're so angry I'm
not going to deal with you I get this on
YouTube comments where people like you
know write write dumb stuff and I'll be
like wow you know you're really off base
on that nobody don't get so angry with
me and I'll think to myself what a dummy
I'm not angry with him how the hell
would he know or she know whether I'm
angry with them you know from from a few
lines that have no tone or context to
them whatsoever so there is kind of a
trope you know oh you're angry so I'm
not going to deal with you so you're
right about that but you know even if
you think anger is a good thing and
you're a philosopher like say Aristotle
you don't think it's uniformly a good
thing and you say most people are
actually bad
we off with respect to it Ulf likings is
there any real substance of virtues in a
consequentialist way something's
considered to be in excess of the nick
of mccain ethics can be beneficial
efficient a CEO who wills himself the
power yeah I mean you want to think that
way about it go ahead the only way that
you find out whether there it's the
answer your question is there real real
substance of virtues yes there's there's
so much substance there that you can't
really see the substance unless you
actually start practicing some of this
stuff that will we'll open that up for
you a good person to read about that is
Alistair McIntyre contemporary author he
discusses how we can you know sort of be
blind to that but I mean if you want to
look at everything in a consequentialist
way go right ahead
you know even the the the great
consequentialist thought you still have
to talk about virtue Bentham does you
know mill does they have to have some
way to work that in so TN pone does the
rage of Achilles come up in any
philosophy yeah it comes up in Plato and
Aristotle and then in the Stoics and you
know they they they reference the rage
of Achilles right alright let's see what
we got here what do I think about Fulton
sheen I don't pay any attention to it
to him he you know I read some of his
stuff early on it was kind of folksy and
all that not not somebody I have the
time to to spend time on I'm sure he's a
good guy but you know who are we
referencing her Bishop Fulton sheen
popular Catholic author from from
earlier in in the last century oh boy
I'm gonna try to close this out because
I gotta get some videos edited and then
I've got another meeting in in less than
an hour western philosophies is from
trombone 7 10,000 foot view all roads
lead through nature to Heidegger
thoughts nope I mean Western philosophy
is a whole buncha roads you don't even
have to go through can't you know you
can you can get
some of what's going on and can't in
other thinkers to like you know say for
example man to be read right and you
know people love to tell these these
narratives these stories that are like a
coherent story almost any simplistic
story about philosophy is gonna be false
so a lot more complicated than that
George Alexander our
sorrow what do you think about feminism
I'm angered about that well it's that's
unfortunate there's a lot of different
kinds of feminism so it's probably
important to distinguish between them
you know one way to do it is to think
about equality versus like gender
feminism so where would somebody like
Mary Wollstonecraft's it in if you
actually read her you'll find that she's
an equality feminist and she would
actually be a great ally of men against
some of the excesses of feminism being
put out there today but you know it's
interesting when I post videos about
Wollstonecraft I get hit from both women
who are like who are you to talk about
Mary Wollstonecraft you know you guys
aren't talking about her and then I'll
have anti feminists who are like you
know typical feminists crap and I'm like
well clearly you haven't read
Wollstonecraft you know so thanks for
the thanks for the chiming in
so is feminism something to be angered
about I mean first you have to actually
say what kind of feminism or what aspect
so that you're angry about and then then
you can go from there
there could be some genuine and justices
that you should be angry about probably
not going to be a helpful strategy to be
angry about it all right Robert I think
the question of good and evil is more
important than calm or anger why pick
why can't just a study both of them
they're both important I don't know
let's see what else we got here you hear
the dog getting all whiney I'm gonna
have to take them out very soon too
Robert as long as a good person doesn't
use anger to do something evil that's
the critical factor that's a nice
criterion I'd say yeah yeah all right so
I'm gonna take a last question because
it's already 1:20 to hear from the good
man so I'm not gonna get to everybody
and I will answer before I do that Davis
duck why you skipped me because as I
everybody knows I start out with the
early questions and then as time goes on
and I get more and more questions than I
get I have to get more selective so you
know that's life all right
the good man any good philosophy topics
to talk about in bars well now that
depends you got even somebody who
actually wants to talk philosophy yeah I
mean a lot of the stuff that we talked
about in terms of philosophy is a way of
life
that stuff you could talk about in a bar
but you've got to you know have somebody
who actually wants to hear it I think
you know talking to anybody in a bar
about stuff that they're not really
interested in is not you know enjoyable
or good manners so but if you have an
interlocutor I mean I've talked with a
lot of people about philosophy in bars
and if you're lucky enough to find an
interlocutor oh here she is but lucky
enough to find an interlocutor who
really wants to talk philosophy then
pretty much anything you want to you
know that you're competent to talk about
the one thing you shouldn't do is just
[ __ ] around and call it philosophy
because then that gives philosophy can
of a bad name so all right so this is
the the sign that it is time for me to
get on with the rest of the day this is
Amica and she I think wants to go
outside is that what you want
you want to go outside all right I'm
signing off thanks for all the questions
and comments and you know try to get as
many as I can
we're already like a twenty five minutes
over so we'll have another one of these
later this month
I also have an AMA session coming up
next Saturday I think
but you can check on you know reason io
or on my facebook page I've got that
stuff posted there now I gotta go take
care of this dog
alright see you later